[Musique]
bonjour bonjour et bienvenue dans
dialogue citoyen nous sommes ensemble
pendant près d'une heure pour faire
échanger le plus directement le plus
sincèrement possible cinq citoyennes et
citoyens qui sont connectés des quatre
coins de la France ils vont échanger
aujourd'hui avec des parlementaires sur
ce plateau autour d'un grand sujet de
préoccupation qui nous concerne tous au
quotidien aujourd'hui on va parler de la
santé de son coout un coout en
augmentation selon une étude qui date du
mois d'avril les frais de santé des
Français ont augmenté de 75 % en 5 ans
alors pourquoi ce soigner coûte-t-il de
plus en plus cher est-ce que l'on va
vers un système à deux vitesses où il va
falloir payer le prix fort pour être
bien soigné comment garantir l'accès aux
soins pour tous on en parle avec cinq
citoyennes et citoyens qui sont
connectés un peu partout dans l'Hexagone
nous allons être aujourd'hui avec
mariechristine Marie-christine qui est
retraité qui est aussi
auto-entrepreneuse et qui va nous parler
de la hausse continue des tarifs de sa
mutuel et notamment cette dernière année
une hausse de 25 % dans cette émission
nous allons être aussi avec Valentin qui
est lui étudiant et qui a fait le choix
de l'hôpital public pour soigner ses
dents et cela plutôt qu'une clinique
privée plus chè mais cela n'a pas été
sans conséquence dans cette émission on
va aussi échanger avec Alexia Alexia qui
est médecin libéral dans l'Aube Alexia
qui se sent aussi libéré depuis qu'elle
a choisi de se déconventionner et elle
va nous expliquer pourquoi elle a fait
cette démarche nous allons aussi être
dans cette émission avec Marie Marie qui
est aidante sa mère est atteinte de la
maladie d'Alzheimer et depuis 5 ans déjà
certains de ces médicaments qu'elle
prend au quotidien ne sont plus
remboursés et enfin pour terminer cette
émission nous serons également avec
abdelalii dont l'association banlieu
santé donne accès aux soins aux plus
précaires et face à eux trois sénateurs
et sénatrices pour répondre et bien à
leur à leurs préoccupations à leurs
questions parfois à leur coup de gueule
nous serons avec Bernard Jomier bonjour
bonjour vous êtes sénateur socialiste de
Paris et vous êtes médecin de profession
à côté de vous Élisabeth doano bonjour
bonjour vous êtes signatrice Union
centriste de la Mayenne et vous êtes la
rapporteur générale du budget de la
Sécurité sociale vous avez beaucoup à
faire en ce moment au Parlement enfin
nous sommes avec Bruno Belin bonjour
bonjour sénateur les républicains de la
Vienne et vous êtesv pharmaciens de
profession et pour commencer cette
émission on va prendre la direction de
bois Colomb dans les haut de scènes où
nous allons écouter Marie-Christine
l'empereur Marie Christine qui a 67 ans
bonjour vous êtes auto-entrepreneuse et
vous faites face à une explosion des
coups de votre mutuel on regarde je suis
retraitée et à ce titre je bénéficie
donc du une mutuelle senior je
m'interroge surtout sur le calcul des
cotisations de la mutuelles comment se
fait-il que ce calcul ne soit fait qu'à
partir de l'âge et non de l'utilisation
que l' fait de cette mutuelle cette
mutuelle je l'ai depuis 3 ans première
augmentation 656 % 1ière année 2è
augmentation 1670 % et dernière
augmentation 2023 25 % donc je me dis
c'est extrêmement
élevé
Marie-Christine vous payez donc votre
mutuel 380 € par mois ça fait plus de
4000 € par an c'est une augmentation
vous l'avez dit de 25 % la dernière
année est-ce que vous savez
pourquoi pourquoi j'ai posé la question
la réponse est relativement floue mais
euh d'après le reportage que j'avais vu
sur une une chaîne concurrente il
paraîtrait que ça viendrait donc le
calcul se fait uniquement sur l'âge des
des assuré vous avez 67 ans et votre
mari est un petit peu plus âgé
1 ans effectivement donc c'est peut-être
ça qui explique cette forte augmentation
de 25 % mais personne ne peut me dire si
réellement c'est ça voilà 81 ans donc
votre mari alors vous voulez poser une
question au sénateur vous voulez les
interpeller sur votre situation
dites-nous et bien justement je vais
reposer ma question
euh pourquoi le calcul des cotisations
annuel de mutuel ne se fait que sur
l'âge des assurés et non sur la
consommation parce que notre cas euh mon
mari et moi nous consommons très peu
cette mutuelle euh donc j'aimerais bien
que ça soit vraiment sur la consommation
et tout un exemple tout bête nous avons
payé nous pirons sur 2023 4300 € et j'ai
fait mon calcul de remboursement Muel
sur l'année 2023 nous dépassons tout
juste les 1200 € donc effectivement ça
je trouve que ça fait très très très
très élevé votre votre réaction à la
situation de Marie-Christine qui qui
vous demande donc et bien pourquoi cette
augmentation dépend de l'âge et pas
manifestement et bien de de la réalité
des soins aujourd'hui bonjour madame à
l'exposé de de votre situation je suis
tout de même très étonnée du montant
effectivement vous avez sans doute fait
des choix euh voilà qui garantissent un
certain niveau de de prise en charge la
réalité aujourd'hui c'est que les
mutuelles elles ont augmenté euh pour
pour tous mais la moyenne est d'environ
5 % pour l'année 2023 elles étaient déjà
pratiquement de 5 % en en 2022 et on
imagine qu'elles seront entre 6 et 8 %
d'augmentation l'année prochaine donc
voyez les choses ne vont pas aller en
s'améliorant c'est une situation qui est
effectivement regrettable pour tous les
assurés mais vous pouvez aussi jouer de
la concurrence hein vous pouvez faire de
la mise en concurrence parce que je
trouve que effffectivement là vous avez
certainement un un prix assez élevé
alors pour pour ce qui est de de l'âge
effectivement il y a cette idée que plus
on est âgé et plus on va avoir besoin en
fait de cette complémentaire santé et
donc ça se comprend mais il y a aussi le
fait que les hommes sont en général
davantage comment dire c'est plus cher
pour un homme que pour une femme et tout
au long de la vie alors donc là ce sont
des des sujets d'assurance de prévalence
et donc c'est c'est c'est lié à des
statistiques en réalité et chaque mutuel
regarde effectivement ça à la loupe afin
proposer des prix qui puissent en tout
cas être en relation
avec le risque le risque de de chacun
selon son âge et selon son sexe
mariechristine vous avez entendu
ellisabeth Donau qui dit ça va augmenter
encore les tarifs des mutuels l'année
prochaine est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire combien ça représente aujourd'hui
dans votre budget est-ce que vous pensez
que bah vous pourriez encore supporter
une nouvelle hausse en
2024 supporter non je pense pas ça
représente quand même environ 20 5 % de
mon budget donc quelque part je me dis
effectivement je je pose des questions
ailleurs que là où je suis assuré je
demande des devis malgré tout il y a pas
grande différence donc je me dis
peut-être que je prendrai des catégorie
inférieure et puis puis on verra on
verra selon les soucis si on a des
soucis ou pas mais bon pour payer un peu
moins cher effectivement alors attendez
on va faire pass on va parler aussi avec
les autres parlementaires Bernard
jaumier est-ce que et bien il faut agir
aujourd'hui soit sur les prix des
mutuels soit sur les critères des
mutuels qu'est-ce que vous pouvez faire
vous en tant que parlementaire bah
bonjour madame d'abord rapidement il y a
deux causes quand même à la hausse de
votre tarif de de mutuel c'est que le
budget santé la santé coûte de plus en
plus cher et la sécurité sociale est en
grand déficit on on VI vient de voter
enfin on va voter cet après-midi le
budgetisabethano et la rapporteur ici et
on voit le déficit augmente et donc la
sécurité sociale elle cherche à à
transférer les dépenses sur d'autres
elle essaie de ne plus prendre en charge
certaines dépenses donc elle elle les
envoie vers les mutuels ou elle les
envoie directement vers les assurés
sociaux c'est par exemple vous avez
suivi le débat sur les franchises
médicales peut-être c'est directement
pour vous et puis la deuxième raison
c'est que dans ce qu'on appelle les
mutueles il y a deux catégories
différentes vous le savez vous madame
vous avez un vrai contrat de mutuel
puisque j'ai vu sur votre facture c'est
vous êtes à la Mutualité Française une
mutuelle la mutualité française mais si
vous aviez 30 ans Madame et que vous
alliez à votre banque la banque elle
vous proposerait une assurance santé une
complémentaire et vous priez pas cher du
tout et les mutuelles elles elles se
retrouvent à prendre en charge beaucoup
de personnes qui ont plus de 60 ans et
dont les frais de santé bah avec l'âge
on a plus de frais de santé en moyenne
c'est comme ça et donc elles sont obligé
d'ugmenter le ne voit pas ça proposé par
sa banque proposera pas si vous allez
dans un grand réseau bancaire que vous
avez 30 ans il vous donne une
mutuelle pour 30 € par mois ou 25 mais
mais quand vous avez plus de 60 ans la
banque elle vous veut pas elle
sélectionne le risque donc les mutuels
ell se retrouve avec les personnes qui
ont le plus de dépenses et donc après
bah elles essayent de voilà est-ce qu'on
peut faire des choses oui bien sûr
d'abord on pourrait arrêter le fait que
la sécurité sociale transfère les
dépenses sur les autres et puis
deuxièmement on pourrait rétablir un peu
d'égalité entre ce qu'on appelle donc la
banque assurance et les vrais mutuels
alors Bruno bin est-ce que vous avez les
même piste est-ce que vous pensez aussi
qu'il faut et bien aujourd'hui agir sur
les mutuels peut-être même les taxés il
y a aussi cette type de proposition qui
sont faites régulièrement d'abord ce
sont des organismes privés le risque
assuranciel est un vrai débat
actuellement on entend bien les
assurances qui sont confrontés sur les
territoires aux questions de séisme
d'inondation qui ne veulent plus assurer
les communes c'est ça peut paraître
décalé par rapport au au propos de
Madame mais c'est la même logique et
puis on retrouve de toute façon derrière
ces groupes les mêmes derrière ces
assurances les les mêmes groupes alors
il y a aussi la conséquence de
finalement ce qu'on vit depuis 30 ans et
et avec les questions de
déconventionnement euh de baisse de
remboursement d'un certain nombre de de
médicaments et tout
ça et tout ça se transfert évidemment
sur des assurances privées qui proposent
d'autres services ou qui ont créé des
services aujourd'hui par la téléphonie
par d'autres outils de communication et
bien évidemment qui paye bah le
consommateur donc l'assuré et donc tout
ça on le retrouve sur la facture que
chaque mutualiste supporte mais c'est
normal c'est inéluctable ou il faut
quand même bien réguler tout ça on
revient toujours à la question que qui
doit payer le service est-ce que c'est
le contribuable et c'est le débat sur la
sécurité sociale mais à un moment donné
il fauda quand même les ressources
est-ce que c'est le consommateur et on
est sur le la question de du risque
assurentiel voilà il n'y a pas d'autre
sources de financement mais je crois que
un système basé sur la solidarité et
l'autre sécurité sociale est vrai
système basé sur la sécurité sur la
solidarité qu'il faut qu'il faut bien
évidemment défendre et donc veiller à ce
que la sécurité sociale ne se désengage
pas il faut comprendre qu'un C nom de
professionnels de santé sont rentrés on
va en parler dans un hors
conventionnement ce qui coûte ce qui
fait que les les mutuels aussi on
prennent en charge différemment et un
tarif élevé merci merci beaucoup à
Marie-Christine d'avoir été avec nous et
d'avoir permis et bien d'aborder ce
sujet on va passer à un deuxème sujet
pour poursuivre cette émission nous
sommes avec trois nouveaux citoyens et
nous allons commencer avec Valentin
Salperwick bonjour Valentin vous avez 23
ans vous êtes étudiant et lors de vos
études pour des soins dentaires coûteux
il s'agissait d'un implant dentaire vous
vous êtes tourné vers le CHU de Rennes
l'hôpital public et le problème c'est
que et bien tout ça vous a pris beaucoup
de temps on va revenir un petit peu sur
votre histoire d'abord Valentin vous
avez choisi l'hôpital parce qu'il vous
avez été d'abord conseillé par votre
médecin mais aussi parce que c'était
moins cher
oui bah tout à fait en fait le l'hôpital
public il a été moi j'ai été adressé
par par mon dentiste de là où d'où je
viens euh j'ai été adressé vers cet
hôpital public qui est donc le CHU de
Rennes qui est un grand hôpital avec
beaucoup de moyens et j'avais fait par
ailleurs plusieurs devis pour une
couronne implant auoporté qui est le
soin dont j'avais besoin et il se trouve
que l'hôpital public était là où c'était
moins cher donc ça a été forcément une
variable déterminante dans mon choix
quelle différence c'était à peu près
entre les entre la clinique et et
l'hôpital
euh alors pour donner une
idée je crois que c'était aux alentours
à l'hôpital c'est aux alentours de à peu
près 1700 1800 € pour une couronne
implant
auorté et en clinique ça pouvait aller
jusqu'au double et quelles conséquences
ça a eu pour vous de passer et bien par
cet
hôpital la conséquence très concrète
c'est que j'ai eu un parcours de soins
qui était assez fractionné parce qu'en
plus j'ai dû partir à l'étranger pendant
mes
études donc j'ai pas eu de suivi pendant
tout à fait en Erasmus ouais j'ai pas eu
de suivi pendant près d'un an ce qui a
entraîné des
complication donc c'est sûr que infin ça
a coûté plus cher à et ça m'a pris
beaucoup plus de temps euh et ça a été
c'est vrai un peu plus compliqué quoi
oui c'était pas un problème de qualité
des soins mais ça serait à refaire
est-ce que vous le referiez comme
ça je pense que je le referai comme ça
mais c'est vrai que si on m'avait dit
que ça avait duré 5 ans et alors que ça
aurait pu être réglé en en un an
euh je me serais beaucoup plus posé la
question c'est sûr c'est sûr he 4 ans au
lieu d'un an ça fait réfléchir vous
voulez poser une question à nos élus
allez-y Valentin
oui en fait tout simplement moi je me
demande
euh comment est-ce qu'on fait pour pour
garantir l'accès aux soins spécialisés
euh l'exemple du dentaire mais il y a
beaucoup de d'autres soins spécialisés
pour les étudiants qui sont une une
popul une population précaire mobile et
qui a finalement peu de moyens Bernard
jaumier votre réponse qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire pour les jeunes pour les
étudiants plus spécif spfiquement
aujourd'hui quand on voit bien la
situation par exemple de Valentin et ben
c'est la question que posait tout à
l'heure Bruno Belin c'est-à-dire la
santé ça coûte qui paye est-ce que c'est
la sécurité sociale est-ce que c'est la
complémentaire ou est-ce que c'est en
reste à charge pour chacun et si on veut
une égalité d'accès au soins si on veut
que ceux qui ont le moins de moyens
puissent aussi se faire soigner les
dents les yeux enfin on en reparlera
peut-être il y a eu le 100 % santé mais
si on veut qu'il qu'il le puiss il faut
que la sécurité sociale elle assume
mieux ses on va dire prestations de base
ses accès de base au soins le sujet
c'est aussi celui de la durée là Bruno
Belin on parle dans cette émission de
médecine à deux vitesses mais là c'était
vraiment au sens propre concernant
Valentin on a vu une médecine plus lente
du côté du public alors que à la
clinique privée était plus rapide he il
a eu des cas autour de lui où ça prenait
un an pour faire le même type de soin
dans une clinique et lui 4 ans c'était
aussi lié à l'engorgement bien sûr de
l'hôpital alors il y a plusieurs
éléments à cette question à ce sujet-là
d'abord effectivement on est eu on était
dans une période où il y a eu cet
engorgement pour reprendre votre
exploation c'estàd une surcharge partout
en raison de la pandémie ce que tout le
monde a a compris il y a aussi tout
simplement parce qu'il faut le dire on
est dans dans ce débat une carence de
professionnels de santé généralisé et
notamment en en dentaire en chirurgie
dentaire en orthodonciie euh
l'implantologie et ça rejoint la
question du coup a énormément augmenté
parce que aujourd'hui vous avez de
nouveaux matériaux on a des imprimantes
3D pour des implantations donc
effectivement un coût qui a augmenté
mais je crois que pour expliquer cette
durée de temps de traitement c'est tout
simplement la carence de professionnel
vous aveit de plus en plus de besoins
avec moins de professionnels disponibles
donc à un moment donné c'est il y a un
embouteillage quelque part c'est juste
que j'ai eu un enfin le le parcours de
soins a été vraiment très très
fractionné beaucoup de rendez-vous euh
et moi ce que je voyais quand j'étais
dans le service c'était que euh les les
internes et et tous les professionnels
de santé enfin ils avaient pas assez
d'encadrant ils avaient pas assez de de
personnes formées autour d'eux donc il y
a forcément je pense un un manque de
moyens et peut-être peut-être
la question des dépenses de santé de
l'État se pose quoi ellisabeth doanau
moi je voudrais dire que sur les
implants et bien toutes les mutuelles
aussi
sont assez assez comment dirais-je
engagé mais pas tant que ça parce que
c'est quand même un travail particulier
que ça coûte cher d'ailleurs vous avez
donné le prix tout à l'heure à l'antenne
et donc l'assurance maladie mais comme
les mutuels c'est peu remboursé et c'est
plutôt de la poche de l'assurée pour
tous les autres actes d' d'ut on logie
est excusez-moi c'est remboursé parce
que vous avez la mutuelle étudiante vous
avez aussi la possibilité de de de la
complémentaire santé solidaire et vous
pouvez aussi avoir accès à des CHU qui
proposent aussi des actes de de soins
gratuits pour les étudiants moi je
connais même des françaises qui
travaillent aujourd'hui en Australie aux
États-Unis au Royaume-Uni qui reviennent
en France pour se faire soigner parce
que elles trouve qu'effectivement elles
sont mieux prises en charge en France
que partout ailleurs où elles sont alors
c'est vrai que pour les implants là il y
a un vide c'est c'est c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui coûte très cher et qui
aujourd'hui n'est pas bien pris en
charge c'est certain eu et pourtant on
voit chez les jeunes en France de plus
en plus de de renoncement au soins c'est
la population où il y a le plus de
renoncement aux soins vous connaissez un
peu des gens autour de vous Valentin
pour qui c'est compliqué de se soigner
dans dans votre génération
aujourd'hui bah moi je le vois enfin
vraiment autour de moi il y a il y a
beaucoup de de renoncement aux soins on
va dire un peu au quotidien de de pas
forcément aller prendre des médicaments
alors qu' en aurait besoin ou alors
qu'on guérirait mieux avec euh et après
il y a beaucoup de renoncement aux soins
un peu sur la longue durée de renoncer à
aller voir des spécialistes parce que
les délais sont vraiment trop long que
ce soit je sais pas allergologue
oftalmo tous ces spécialistesl euh quand
on est quand on est enfin actif en
général mais encore plus public précaire
jeune sans beaucoup de moyens et sans
beaucoup de temps c'est c'est il y a il
y a un peu une intersection des soucis
quoi euh votre réaction Bernard jaumier
he surû et bien aujourd'hui les
difficultés de ces de certains de de ces
jeunes à se soigner est-ce que ça va
devenir un problème de santé publique
est-ce qu'on se prépare quand même des
difficultés à l'avenir hein ces jeunes
ils seront pas jeunes à vitam etternam
moi ce ce qui me désole un peu c'est que
on arrive pas à avoir un débat national
pour dire quelles sont les priorités
parce que on peut pas tout financer en
santé c'est clair mais à laisser le
système se trouer comme ça bah c'est
ceux qui ont le moins de moyens qui sont
le plus en difficulté donc les étudiants
qui ont pas beaucoup d'argent des
publics qui sont précaires et cetera qui
pour X moyen d'ailleurs pas toujours que
financiers hein parce que c'est il
suffit pas d'avoir la la C2S enfin
c'était la CMU pour ceux qui suivent pas
voilà il pas d'avoir la CMU pour dire
c'est bon tout est pris en charge à 100
% il y a d'autres freins et monsieur
vient d'en donner un c'est qu'il faut
être en capacité d'accéder aux soins de
spécialité notamment il faut savoir à
qui s'adresser il faut savoir où aller
et donc ça c'est compliqué aussi donc un
système qui est en train de se
contracter hein bon et ben c'est un
système où les plus précaires c'est les
premiers à payer la note et ça c'est pas
normal Prem merci merci beaucoup
Valentin pour votre témoignage et pour
votre échange avec nos sénateurs et
sénatrices vous avez parlé à l'instant
des des mauvaises conditions de travail
à l'hôpital euh les patients qui
s'enchaînent à un ryth infernal c'est
aussi l'une des raisons pour lesquelles
le docteur Alexia Michelin a choisi de
se déconventionner Alexia Michelin
bonjour vous êtes médecin libéral vous
avez 36 ans vous exercez depuis 8 ans à
estisac c'est dans l'Aube et vous avez
décidé récemment de vous déconventionner
ce qui a eu pour effet de réduire le
nombre de patients que vous voyez chaque
jour et voilà comment vous vous sentez
après une journée de consultation on
regarde
il est 19h je termine ma journée de
consultation donc j'ai vu aujourd'hui 20
patients contre le double il y a
quelques mois certains diront que j'ai
vu deux fois moins de patients que
auparavant moi je dirais que je les ai
vu de façon beaucoup plus qualitative et
que c'est un meilleur service rendu ça
contribue également à limiter mon
épuisement professionnel et à me
permettre de poursuivre mon activité
chose que je n'étais pas du tout
certaine de pouvoir faire et il y a
quelques mois tant j'étais fatigué alors
on entend alexiia votre fatigue lorsque
vous étiez conventionné est-ce que un
peu plus en détail vous pouvez nous
expliquer ce qui posait problème dans le
conventionnement est-ce que c'était le
tarif est-ce que c'était la paperasque
est-ce que c'était les obligations de de
l'Assurance Maladie
expliquez-nous en fait ça a été un petit
peu un tout c'est-à-dire que euh c'était
le moment en fait des négociations
conventionnelles j'étais épuisée par le
nombre de patients euh et puis
l'évolution de la médecine générale
proposée au moment des négociations
conventionnelles avec la délégation de
tâche les
téléconsultations et puis plus la la
lourdeur administrative et
organisationnelle qui a imposé par le
secteur 1 ça a été trop pour moi et en
fait j'ai décidé de de de de Me
déconventionner et du coup quel est le
tarif de votre consultation aujourd'hui
euh c'est 40 € la consultation 40 €
alors c'est 26,50 € aujourd'hui la
consultation conventionnée est-ce que
vous vous avez eu des patients qui vous
ont fait de reproches est-ce qu'il y en
a qui vous ont dit bien on va plus
pouvoir venir qui ont considéré que
c'était je sais pas égoïste par
exemple bien sûr après on a toujours les
réponses moi personnellement je pense
que c'est pas moi qui limite l'accès à
mes soins c'est plutôt le tarif
d'autorité le tarif d'autorité c'est pas
moi qui le fixe donc en fait c'est pas
c'est c'est voilà moi je décide de mes
conditions de travail j'ai décidé que je
ne souhaitais plus travailler avec la
convention parce qu'elle ne me convient
pas en l'état actuel des choses et après
c'est pas c'est pas ma faute en fait si
les patients ne peuvent pas accéder
financièrement à mes soins le le le
tarif d'autorité c'est 26,50 € hein
c'est bien ça c'est le tarif non c'est
qu quel qu'est-ce que c'est comme tarif
exc expliquez-moi le tarif d'autorité
c'est le tarif de remboursement des
consultations des médecins non
conventionnés et il est fixé à 61
centimes 61 voilà 61 centimes c'est ce
que le remboursement auquel vos patients
ont droit aujourd'hui en payant la
consultation à 40 € c'est d'ailleurs
quelque chose que vous souhaiteriez
changer
j'imagine bien sûr c'est sûr que ce
serait l'idéal en fait on leur offre une
meilleure médecine et vous avez
l'impression aujourd'hui de faire mieux
votre métier avec avec vos patient il y
a aucun doute AUC aucun doute vous aviez
une question vous vouliez interpeller
nos parlementaires
oui la question que j'aimerais leur
poser c'est comment comptez-vous
améliorer la qualité de travail des
médecins généralistes pour éviter juste
qu'ils en viennent à faire à se
déconventionner Bernard jumier bon en
tant que parlementaire et aussi en tant
que médecin est-ce que vous comprenez ce
choix de déconventionnement alors
professionnellement oui donc je je suis
médecin généraliste aussi et j'exerce et
je trouve ça
insupportable de devoir voir 40
personnes par jour on travaille pas bien
d'abord et puis on s'épuise soi-même
vous exercez un jour par semaine encore
moi çaer un jour par semaine et de toute
façon j'ai jamais vu je trouve que hors
épidémie ou bon voilà c'est obligé mais
sinon c'est pas comme ça qu'on fait de
la bonne médecine et d'ailleurs regarder
en permanence les pouvoirs publics même
les parlementaires hein quand ils
débattent de texte disent au médecin ah
lors des consultations il faudra que
vous pensiez à faire c faudra que vous
pensiez à faire la prévention faudra que
vous pensiez à lutter à prévenir les
violences et cetera on le demande de
faire des tas de choses mais en 3
minutes 30 maintenant donc allez d'un
point de vue professionnel je comprends
tout à fait et d'un point de vue
politique non mais d'un point de vue
collectif après d'un point de vue
collectif le résultat c'est que des tas
de gens ne vont pas pas pouvoir accéder
à cette bonne médecine parce que ceux
qui peuvent accéder c'est ceux qui ont
une mutuelle qui va compléter les 61
centimes ou ceux qui sont assez riche
pour sortir 40 € de leur poche à chaque
fois donc d'un point de vue collectif
c'est pas possible mais ce que ça
raconte et je j' rester là mais c'est
que si on ne remet pas sur pied un
système où on peut être soigné dans de
bonnes conditions ça va aboutir à ça
c'estàdire des médecins qui se
déconventionnent les plus riches qui
sont bien soignés et les autres à la
chaîne alors Bruno Belin qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire j'en reviens à la à la
question que pose le docteur Alexa
Michelin qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire pour
améliorer la qualité de travail des
médecins conventionnés pour éviter ben c
des conventionnements qui on le voit ben
vont être un problème collectivement
sinon moi j'ai une position aussi très
simple c'était sur il y a eu un grand
débat sur la cooherition doit-on un
moment donné pour régler les
professionnels de santé comme si on en
avait comme ça un stock miraculeux
quelque part leur forcer être sur les
territoires on aurait vu que ça que des
déconventionnement et et donc ce que
l'on peut regretter et je partage la
position de Bernard jumier sur cette
notion de voilà d'un des grands progrès
de la France de permettre la santé à
tous on on aurait évidemment un effet
contre-productif moi je comprends la
réaction à la fois qualitative mais
aussi d'avoir le temps de mieux soigner
alors il faudrait trouver un système qui
reprenne les deux pour cela bah il faut
plus de professionnels de santé de tout
le débat depuis une demi-heure qu' on
discute sur ce sujet il est
la conclusion ou du moins
l'aboutissement d'une carence habissale
de professionnel de santé parce que
pourquoi aujourd'hui un jeune médecin se
trouve avec un carnet de rendez-vous à
45 contactes dans la journée on le voit
bah il en a il a peur il fuit c'est
parce que on manque de professionnel de
santé parce que c'est l'aboutissement de
très mauvaises décisions depuis 30 ans
Elisabeth Doan peut-être un mot sur
quand même comment fonctionne le
conventionnement que nos téléspectateurs
comprennent les médecins ils touchent 26
€ par consultation et en plus il y a un
complément de l'Assurance Maladie
comment comment ça marche bien en
réalité sur
26,50 € de consultation vous avez une
partie qui est pris en charge par la
complémentaire c'est dans les environs
de 7 € je crois et pour le patient c'est
1 € ou et et et et le médecin ce qu'il
perçoit c'est 26,50 € ou c'est alors le
médecin non il reçoit en plus enfin il
reçoit comment le remboursement de
l'Assurance maladie mais après il peut y
avoir aussi des forfaits pour la
structure ou pour aussi l'implication
dans dans la coordination des soins et
cetera donc ça ne se limite pas en fait
à 26,50 € ça dépend en fait de comment
on est organisé dans le travail et dans
quel endroit on travaille moi je
voudrais dire que je comprends tout à
fait la réaction de ce médecin parce que
aujourd'hui c'est infernal de faire
finalement du rendement de de la visite
comme ça euh comment à suivre et euh
mais en même temps c'est que 0 7 % des
110000 médecins libéraux qui travaillent
aujourd'hui en France donc c'est
effectivement pas beaucoup de médecins
qui vont se déconventionner mais
effectivement faut être attentif parce
que si on ne fait rien si on ne trouve
pas des solutions pour qu'il travaillent
correctement et bien ça va augmenter et
j'ai posé la question à Monsieur fantô
justement qui est le directeur justement
de de de la Caisse Primaire d'Assurance
maladiie il me disait qu'il y avait pas
beaucoup l'année dernière je crois que
c'est 25 à peu près médecins qui ont
fait ce choix mais moi je voulais poser
la question question à ce médecin est-ce
que vous avez eu la possibilité aussi de
de de travailler avec le groupe dans
lequel vous êtes est-ce que vous êtes
dans une maison de santé
plurisciplinaire est-ce que vous êtes
dans un centre de santé parce que on
peut aussi avoir cette qualité
d'exercice en travaillant avec les
autres professionnels de là où on est et
s'organiser alexand n'est pas seul dans
son cabinet c'est ce que j'ai cru
comprendre
dites-nous en fait donc je suis
installée dans un pôle de santé mais
c'est pas du tout une maison de santé
pluridisciplinaire c'est quelque chose
de de de privé c'est donc on est trois
médecins des infirmiers des kinés euh et
puis euh et puis d'autres professionnels
de santé euh les deux autres médecins
sont proches de la retraite donc en fait
dans moins de 5 ans je suis toute seule
ici en plus donc ça a aussi contribué à
mon épuisement et on a quand même eu un
une pression de la part des patients qui
est quand même importante he faut se
rendre compte que si je faisais 40
consultations par jour c'était pas parce
que c'était vraiment parce que j'avais
une pression tous les jours j'avais des
des demandes de de R
chose que j'ai plus aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment un confort vous
dites que vous n'avez plus ces demandes
de rajout mais j'imagine que ces
patients ils existe toujours est-ce que
vous savez bien comment ils se font
soigner aujourd'hui du coup alors alors
en fait il y en a forcément certains qui
sont partis il y en a certains qui sont
restés et c'est surtout que les demandes
sont différentes c'estd que on a des
consultations qui sont nécessaires j'ai
des patients qui viennent rechercher
vraiment vraiment un avis médical et
plus et plus uniquement un document
administratif où on n plus uniquement
prestataire de soins c'est enfin
prestataire vraiment de service entre
guillemets il y a vraiment une relation
de confiance qui s'est de nouveau
établie avec mes
patients et Alex est-ce qu'il y aurait
des raisons qui pourraient vous faire
revenir au conventionnement qu'est-ce
qui il faudrait changer pour que vous
choisissiez de vous reconventionner par
exemple
ah bah déjà il faudrait des des
probablement des conditions de de au
niveau de la convention qui soi
différent c'estàd que là la la
convention secteur 1 enfin ce qu'on a
parlé avant les forfaits utiliser le
logiciel qui qui plante en permanence
depuis le séure c'est pas possible quoi
enfin c'était une charge psychologique
qui était alors c'est des choses que les
patients ils ne voient pas mais mais
pour nous au quotidien c'est notre outil
de travail et ce logiciel c'était un
poids je rallumé mon ordinateur trois
quatre fois CIN fois par jour c'était
pas possible euh 5 minutes pour lire une
carte Vitale non c'est pas possible
enfin c'est des petites choses mais en
fait bout à bout ça les cotations les
cotations pour les actes c'est enfin
voilà la nomenclature après vous devez
vérifier les paiements vous devez
justifier vos cotations parfois on vous
vous faites des choses en tiers payant
vous devez vérifier vos tiers payants on
ne vous pay pas la complexité
administrative quoi voilà c'est ça pour
plus que le tarif hein c'est
tarif aussi j'imagine que c'est vous
avez quand même augmenté à 40 € vos
consultation alors moi je me suis jamais
plain de mon de mon revenu après c'est
vrai que par rapport aux charges on est
comme tout le monde l'inflation ça nous
touche aussi et donc j'avais forcément
un un un un rythme de vie qui diminuait
forcément mais c'était pas ça la
principale problématique c'était
vraiment la charge de travail et et un
métier qui en fait qui n'évolue pas vers
quelque chose qui me correspond
c'est-à-dire la délégation de tâche le
la téléconsultation que je ne cautionne
pas du tout ce genre de chos quoi merci
merci beaucoup Alexa Michelin d'être
intervenu d'avoir témoigné dans notre
émission on a beaucoup parlé de
l'Assurance Maladie hein depuis le début
de cette émission on va continuer à en
parler l'assurance maladie qui prend en
charge le remboursement des médicaments
parfois en totalité parfois en partie
parfois plus du tout c'est le cas de
certains médicaments qui sont utilisés
dans le cadre de la maladie d'Alzheimer
il traiteent ces médicaments plutôt les
symptômes de la maladie hein ils ne
permettent pas de guérir ils ne sont
plus remboursés depuis 2018 et pour
parler de ce sujet nous sommes à avec
Marie ler bonjour Marie vous êtes
aidante vous êtes aussi aide soignante
de profession votre mère est atteinte de
la maladie d'Alzheimer et elle prend ses
médicaments on va aller voir ces
médicament voici le médicament que ma
maman prend tous les midis le médicament
n'est pas remboursé depuis quelques
années sous prétexte qu' n'a plus
d'effet ça fait une dizaine d'années
qu'elle prend ce traitement et sa
maladie évolue très très très très
lentement à ce jour elle nous reconnaît
ses enfants ses petits-enfants et ses
arrières petits-enfants toujours
cohérentes voici l'ordonnance de ma
petite maman
ebitia 10 mg un par
jour voici la feuille de soin où nous
prenons le
mémantine un par jour et la facture
s'élève à
29,57 pour 2 mois
voilà on voit et bien donc le coût que
représente ce médicament environ 30 €
tous les 2 mois c'est un budget lourd
pour vous aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que ça
représente par rapport et bien à
l'ensemble du traitement de votre de
votre
mère bonjour à tous euh bon pour petit
moment effectivement ça représente un
petit budget bon sachant quand même
qu'elle a une
retraite c'est voilà mais le problème
c'est que comment ce médicament a été
remboursé il y a dizaine d'années et
sous prétexte que il y a des effets
indésirables donc ça a
été déremboursé
et quand j'ai vu le neurologue qui est à
la pointe de la Pitié
Salpétrière quand il m'a dit bah écoutez
si votre maman elle est
moyenille vivement de continuer son
traitement parce que pour moi
effectivement elle
est avec ce tra avec ce médicament même
généricable on peut continuer oui donc
vous dites que votre neurologue en tout
cas vous a dit que ce médicament il
fonctionne par rapport à la maladie de
votre mère mais ça vient s'opposer aussi
à l'AVE de la Haute Autorité de Santé
hein qui dit que l'efficacité est au
mieux modeste qui parle d'effet
indésirable donc est-ce que vous
entendez il y a comme une contradiction
entre les deux sachant que fait partie
des 30 % où la maladie elle n'évolue pas
parce que depuis qu'elle a ce traitement
depuis une dizaine d'années B forcément
elle est beaucoup plus sereine moins
moins
énervée donc vous trouvez est-ce que
vous trouvez ça injuste comme décision
par rapport à la situation de de de
votre maman en même temps vous l'avez
dit hein peut-être pour 70 % des
patients ce n'était pas efficace
oui je trouve ça injuste parce que bon
pourquoi ils ont déremboursé ce ce
médicament ça veut dire qu'il y a une
certaine
catégorie de patients Ben qui ne peuvent
plus se payer effectivement parce que 15
€ par mois ben oui c'est aussi un budget
qui rentre dans un produit qui n'est
plus remboursé et qui ser rajoute bien
sûr au reste des des soins pour la
maladie vous voulez interpeller nos
sénateurs quelle est la question que
vous voulez
poser je voudrais savoir si justement
comment le remettre sur le marché ce
médicament
et le faire rembourser et bien sûr ce
qui soit remboursé au moins au 100 % ou
éventuellement avec une mutuelle qui
arrive
derrière Bruno bin votre réaction à
cette
situation de de Marie Legrand qu'est-ce
que ça vous inspire pourquoi
dérembbourser et bien donc ces
médicaments n nous nous dit cette dame
alors que elle en constate les effets
bénéfique pour sa maman et également son
neurologue bonjour madame alors je suis
pas surpris évidemment par euh votre
intervention et je la comprends je
l'entends dans mon officine toutes les
semaines puisque ce type de situation on
la connais je suis pharmacien d'officine
en activité euh les remboursements de
médicaments ce n'est pas le Parlement
qui le fixe ce ne sont pas non plus les
professionnels de santé qui les fixent
c'est une autorité indépendante qui se
base sur ce qu'on appelle le service
médical rendu la Haute Autorité de Santé
et donc ce service médical rendu on peut
y avoir tous les débats qu'on veut et on
découvre un jour que tel médicament
pourtant connu mature va avoir son taux
de remboursement à baissé on a inventé
un jour les vignates orange comme on
avait avantant avant invité inventé les
vignettes bleues pour les plus anciens
entre nous mais vous voyez son médecin
qui continue à lui prescrire ce
médicament c'est là que liberté et je
respecte totalement la liberté de chaque
médecin de d'approche de son patient
elle est non négociable et non
discutable chaque médecin a l'approche
qu'il souhaite avec son patient nous
professionnel de santé nous faisons avec
ce que la Haute Autorité de Santé dit en
fonction des études rendues des cas
cliniques des situations de la
pharmacovigilance tout ça on en est
abuvré abreuvé toutes les semaines il y
a eu peut-être à un moment donné un
débat sur l'économie on a tous connu le
sargor remboursé le MC2 remboursé voilà
bon ça été le cas sur certains
médicaments voilà et pourtant tu sais
que le magnésium est important enfin on
pourrait voilà on pourrait avoir des
exemples comme
ça c'est la notion de service méd qui le
rendu qui est aujourd'hui en permanence
sur la table sur les questions de
remboursement et c'est vrai que nous
n'en avons pas évidemment le lie je suis
désolé de pas vous apporter de réponse
même si je comprends totalement
l'injustice que vous ressentez euh face
à ce qui est pour vous évidemment
pénalisant Bernard jaumier une des
questions qu'on se pose c'est que si
vraiment et bien ces médicaments ne sont
pas bons hein pour dire pour parler
rapidement pourquoi est-ce qu'on arrête
pas de les vendre tout simplement
pourquoi est-ce que on on augmente leur
prix euh et où on les dérembourse mais
c'est une bonne question c'est une bonne
question mais malheureusement en fait le
le les médicaments coûtent de plus en
plus cher chaque année je crois que
c'est 7 ou 8 % qu'on consacre de plus au
budget médicament dans notre pays et
donc il y a eu effectivement des des
remboursements qui servaient à faire des
économies mais en général dans ce cas-là
c'est pas des remboursés complètement
c'est abaissé comme ça les mutuels
prennent d'ailleurs c'est encore le
débat de tout à l'heure c'est les
mutuels qui ont la charge du du
complément bon mais il y a des
médicaments qui sont déremboursés
complètement parce qu'effectivement à la
suite d'une procédure il est estimer
qu'ils n'ont pas assez d'efficacité et
qu'au fond ils servent pas à grand-chose
ce qui est terrible c'est que la maman
de madame a une maladie qu'on connaît
tous bien et qui est extrêmement dur à
vivre et quand on a un médicament y
compris qui probablement fait peu
d'effet mais peut-être un peu plus chez
chez la maman de Madame ou autre mais en
tout cas la situation est plutôt
relativement bonne c'est ça règle la
règle du remboursement ou du
dérembboursement elle est pas
individuelle parce que elle ne pourrait
pas être individuelle sinon on
maîtriserait rien du tout madame vit une
situation personnelle où effectivement
le médecin en conscience dit bah
continuez-le elle le supporte bien et
puis si ça sert un peu et ben autant le
continuer et elle se retrouve confrontée
à une règle collective qui paraît
injuste mais je dirais que sur la
maladie d'Alzheimer au fond ça fait
partie de ces domaines dans lesquels il
y a beaucoup de choses qu'on a du mal à
faire pour des raisons de coût
d'ailleurs madame aide sa mère si j'ai
bien compris elle est aidante est-ce que
les dispositifs d'aide humain sont
suffisants est-ce que le soutien aux
aidents est suffisant non vous voyez
c'est tout ça et quand on fait pas assez
sur tout ça et ben on finit par dire le
médicament devient l'objet essentiel
vous voyez ce que je veux dire il
devient l'objet essentiel alors que
peut-être qu'il ne l'est pas marierand
est-ce que et bien vous vous êtes vous
pouvez assurer cette aide correcte
est-ce que vous êtes aidé aujourd'hui
ben je suis très peu aidé hein parce que
bon c'est un coup he d'aider sa roman
bon je j'ai elle a quand même elle
touche la pas et tout ça mais s'il
fallait que je prenne une association ou
à 24 € de l'heure et moi je passe quand
même entre 4 et 5 he par jour voyez ce
que ça pourrait coûter sur sa retraite
bah pourrait pas subvenir donc ben
effectivement c'est moi qui qui ai pris
le le relais et puis je voulais faire
une parenthèse par rapport aux
médicaments là qui sont pas
remboursés le
médicament autrefois il valait je sais
pas 15 ou 20 € la qui était remboursé à
100 % par la SC et là il a été multiplié
par de voire par 3 et puis d'un d'un
pharmacien à l'autre on a forcément des
fois 30 % de
d'augmentation qui n'est pas du tout le
même Taru d'un alors il faut que je
m'amuse à faire toutes les pharmacies
pour dire bah je vais payer payer la
boîte la moins chère c'est c'est
inadmissible oui moi je pense qu'il
devrait y avoir un prix quand un
médicament n'est plus remboursé un prix
fixe c'està-dire bon ben qu'on le
rembourse plus d'accord mais qu'on
augmente pas de 30 à 40 % la boîte alors
notre parlementaire ellisabeth don
qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire cette
situation c'est vrai comme abant de
devoir aller de pharmacie en pharmacie
sur un médicament de ce type pour
essayer de trouver le moins cher oui oui
c'est c'est parfaitement choquant de de
voir qu'effectivement un un médicament
va se vendre avec 30 % de différent de
différence d'une officine à l'autre un
prix unique du livre il pour y avoir un
prix unique du médicament tout à fait
tout à fait mais ça me donne en fait
l'idée de de de de poursuivre cette
conversation à travers une commission
d'enquête parce que euh on on on
pourrait effectivement sur les sujets
que nous abordons ensemble aujourd'hui
euh aller plus loin et essayer de voilà
de faire des propositions pour de
futures lois possiblement ou alors des
changements au niveau de des
remboursements d'assurance maladie et
des mutuell merci beaucoup he marie en
tout cas pour votre témoignage et vous
entendez hein les parlementaires qui
sont interpellés sur votre situation he
qui pourra essayer d'engager des travaux
parlementaire sur ce sujet et bon
courage surtout hein comme édante auprès
de votre maman merci beaucoup pour
terminer cette émission nous allons voir
une initiative qui émane du terrain une
initiative qui est là pour permettre au
plus précairees au plus modestes d'avoir
accès aux soins nous sommes avec Abdel
Ali El Badaoui bonjour vous avez bonjour
banué 2018 une association vous présidez
elle agit à la fois en région parisienne
et à Marseille on
regarde bonjour je m'appelle abdelalii
je suis infirmier de profession et le
président et fondateur de banlieu santé
B santé est une organisation qui lutte
contre les inégalités sociales de santé
il y a 10 ans d'écart d'espérance de vie
entre ouvriers et cadre sup notre enjeu
c'est de raccorder les patients les plus
vulnérables au droit commun et le droit
à la santé alors Abdel Ali 10 ans
d'espérance de vie d'écart entre un
cadre et un ouvrier c'est énorme alors
quel type d'opération vous mettez
aujourd'hui en place avec votre
association pour essayer de un petit peu
rééquilibrer la
balance bonjour à tous et à toutes merci
de nous donner la parole aujourd'hui
notre enjeu à nous effectivement c'est
de réduire les inégalités sociales de
santé mais avoir une vision terrain
c'està-dire que pour nous il est
essentiel d'embarquer les habitants de
faire en sorte que les institutions de
santé les ins atique travaille ensemble
pour réduire ces inégalités sociales en
santé donc on dépl de vitesse vous le
constatez vous au quotidien
oui ben forcément aujourd'hui euh on le
voit ben sinon on serait pas sur le
terrain à développer des projets hein
notamment on déploie des centres de
santé participatifs mais aussi des lieux
de vie comme le café des femmes euh on
voit bien qu'il y a un décrochement
aujourd'hui de la santé par les
populations les plus vulnérables celle
qui aujourd'hui vit un mille feuilles
égalité sociale de santé c'est important
de le dire en cette période très
difficile c'est qui ces populations
vulnérables qui est-ce que vous voyez le
plus dans vos opérations bah c'est
simple ce sont des patients qui sont en
angle mort des politiques publiques et
des politiques de santé publique c'està-
dire que ça peut être monsieur et madame
tout le monde finalement qui même
parfois a des droits mais ne va pas au
devant pour aller se faire soigner
d'ailleurs ce qu'on appelle le recours
le recours tardif à la santé tout
simplement et donc donc il y a tout un
billet et tout tout cela il faut
accompagner ces patients prendre le
temps de les écouter et puis je pense
faciliter l'accès aux soins rendre
quelque chose de beaucoup plus tangible
et faire en sorte queon puisse avoir
aussi une forme d'intermédiaire entre
les prop le santé et les patients pour
pouvoir raccorder ses patients à la
santé euh on le voit ellisabeth douano
cette distance parfois que l'on peut
avoir avec la santé ce n'est pas qu'un
problème financier c'est ce que on nous
explique là c'est parfois le le non
recours parce qu'on connaît pas ses
droits on sait pas comment ça marche ça
c'est un vrai problème aujourd'hui pour
accéder au SO oui les raisons de ne pas
aller se faire soigner elles sont
multiples il y a effectivement l'aspect
financier mais que pour 25 % je crois
des nonreours mais euh il y a aussi le
fait que on a un rapport à la santé qui
est parfois compliqué c'est-à-dire qu'on
a peur qu'on nous découvre une maladie
soudaine qui va être grave et cetera et
ça c'est pour beaucoup de personnes
quelque chose qui les empêche finalement
d'aller consulter et puis il il y a
différentes autres raisons parce que il
y a effectivement un problème d'accès au
soins aujourd'hui sur les territoires
parce que là vous parlez des problèmes
de quartier mais dans les territoires
ruraux on a aussi ce phénomène làin on a
des espaces où on est très très éloigné
de l'accès à un spécialiste de l'accès
même à un médecin généraliste donc je
crois que ce qu'il faut développer
aujourd'hui c'est l'allé vert il y a des
propositions aujourd'hui du gouvernement
pour avoir des des des des miniar qui
puissent voilà se poser à tel endroit et
être V visible être en proximité c'est
ce type d'opération he que fait
aujourd'hui je salue l'opération que
monsieur vient de nous présenter parce
que effectivement autour d'un café
autour d'une autre activité et bien
tiens qu'est-ce que tu as fait est-ce
que tu as fait ta mammographie on est
octobre rose en ce moment est-ce que
voilà tu y as pensé enfin c'est à des
moments comme ça que justement on
oriente les personnes vers l'instinct
qu'on devrait avoir systématique à se
faire consulter de temps en temps pour
faire un petit point un petit checkup
Abdal vous avez une question pour N
parlementaire quelle question vous
voulez leur poser oui oui oui juste pour
donner un élément aussi de langage très
rapide parce qu'elle parlait
effectivement madame la sénatrice des
ruralité nous banlieu veut dire lieu
bannie la mise au banc toutes celles et
ceux qui sont loin du droit commun
important parce que en fait notre enjeu
c'est vraiment d'aller chercher les
patients là où ils sont juste pour
effectivement ma question très simple
c'est aujourd'hui les sénateurs ont voté
ou en tout cas on il a une motion sur la
question de l'Ame quel est
aujourd'hui le sujet comment vous allez
réintégrer finalement ces populations
les plus vulnérables au parcours de
soins parce que vous le savez mieux que
moi aujourd'hui les rapports le disent
euh diminuer je dirais la part de la
sécurité sociale diminuer les droits va
augmenter les coût de santé publique et
de politique publique aujourd'hui et
donc il est éminemment important que
cette dernière digue qui est la santé
qui continue à nous rassembler et faire
commun elle puisse continuer à résister
pour le droit commun Brunau Belin votre
votre réponse vous entendez un petit peu
l'inquiétude du débat général qui a été
suscité aussi he bon par le débat sur
l'aide médicale d'État c'est un sujet
bien particulier qui concerne les les
étrangers mais voilà l'ensemble du
contexte peut t inquiéter vis-à-vis des
plus précaires en tout cas tant qu'on
aura pas réglé cette question là est-ce
qu' va prendre 6 7 ans on sait très bien
parce que la démographie est une science
exacte et la démographie des
professionnels de santé on la connaît
tant qu'on a'ura pas une quantité un
stock suffisant de professionnels de
santé et bien on est face à des
difficult
Bernard jaumier le mot de la conclusion
sur ce sujet c'est la responsabilité des
pouvoirs publics peut-être aussi et bien
de mettre l'accent sur les population
précaire aujourd'hui vous dites c'est
ceux qui qui qui vont le plus souffrir
aujourd'hui dans dans notre système de
santé ce qui est intéressant en fait
dans ce que vous faites ce que ça ce que
ça dit d'abord c'est que ça illustre
tous les intervenants précédents c'estàd
que les populations dont vous vous
occupez les gens les plus précaire c'est
un problème la mutuelle c'est un
problème l' soin de spécialité et cetera
et cetera et surtout ça aussi qu'il faut
qu'on fasse de la santé pas dans la
verticalité descendante comme on le fait
uniquement maintenant maintenant mais en
remontant en faisant construire les
objectifs et les priorités de santé par
ce qui se passe dans les territoires et
juste un mot mais moi je suis dans une
région l'île-de-fance où il y a une
ligne de transport en commun qui
s'appelle le RERB entre le nord du RERB
les gens qui vivent au nord et les gens
qui vivent au sud il y a bien ces 10 ans
de différence d'espérance de vie et ça
montre que les réponses elles ne sont
pas les mêmes au nord qu'au sud de cette
ligne et c'est ça le travail que vous
faites donc ça c'est c'est la bonne
méthode on arrive à la conclusion de
cette émission un mot Élisabeth Donau
sur ce que vous retenez de ces échanges
bien écoutez en tout cas ça nous donne
des perspectives de de de prospection
pour les les sénatrices et les sénateurs
de toute façon les dépenses de santé
iront en augmentant parce que c'est les
technologies c'est le prix des des
nouvelles molécules et donc euh il
faudra effectivement euh travailler au
remboursement que que l'assuré ne soit
pas totalement comment en difficulté
d'accès aux soins parce que c'est un
souci financier il faudra vraiment y
réfléchir de toute façon le pourquo pas
une nouvelle commission d'enquête vous
nous disiez tout à l'heure exactement ou
euh une mission d'information en tout
cas on a une mission d'évaluation qui
s'appelle la mex où on peut travailler
sur ces sujets-là j'inviterai mes mes
collègues en tout cas à réfléchir sur
ces sujets que nous avons vu tout à
l'heure avec vous c'est extrêmement
important qu'on regarde qu'on place
l'assuré au cœur du dispositif de santé
mais qu'il puisse justement se
permettrez d'user des professionnels de
santé si je puis dire sans trop payer
allez le mot de la fin Bruno Belin pour
pour vous et pareil sur ce que vous
retenez de de ces échang obligation de
moyens parce que la santé est
essentielle on aurait pu parler aussi de
la pénurie de médicen qui est aussi un
frein d'accès à la santé et
donc oui oui le chantier est vaste et
bien merci merci beaucoup à tous les
trois merci à tous nos citoyens merci à
Marie-Christine merci à Valentin merci à
Alexia à Marie à Abdel Ali d'avoir
accepté de livrer leurs expériences
leurs problèmes leurs initiatives sur ce
sujet qui nous concerne tous celui de la
santé celui de son cout aujourd'hui et
le sujet également de l'inégal accès aux
soins merci à vous trois d'avoir joué le
jeu de l'échange direct de l'écoute du
débat citoyen et on se retrouve le mois
prochain pour un nouveau numéro de
dialogue citoyen ils ont été ben déjà à
l'écoute et puis ils ont su répondre aux
questions super intéressant et c'était
fluide et tout non pas de souci céit
très bien il y a pas de réponse concrète
à la question c'est sûr de toute façon
pour moi il fa faudrait réformer en
profondeur le système de santé une
émission qui est quand même
enrichissante il faut dire les choses
maintenant le résultat je ne sais pas on
[Musique]
verra